stripped away by Lee in the technical
and having words with Jordan pool as
well how about tomorrow Carolyn his
first native is a rockets and ago and so
Scott
here
well there was pushing and shoving
before so I only saw the motion of the
technical I didn't see who they assigned
it to I think it was to Westbrook
because he said what you going to do and
I think the officials are going to take
a look at this to see what all
transpired and now you've got clay
Thompson having words marques first was
getting into
well if it's Russell Westbrook who draws
the tea that'll be his second he'll be
ejected now loonies
standing in westbrook's away and
trying to restore order here these three
officials not a lot of love lost between
these two organizations because of the
playoff history now I know a lot of
players are different Westbrook is still
have
words here and you're right this would
be his second technical
[Applause]
significantly in the
this could be the end of
and why would you leave it at this point
right let's see you're all this started
here Oh a chef my West yeah why only a
son that's what started everything on
Westbrook says what you're gonna do here
and Toscano Anderson swipes the ball
from it so they've got to look at all
this obviously the guilty party here is
Westbrook right there yeah uncalled yeah
[Applause]
that's what started everything nosy so
Westbrook will be gone
so that's the end of his night
[Applause]
points for West
now here's the problem we've got a long
and they should be on the right side and
they should
[Applause]
[Music]
and I could not be any worse as he's
walking
take it a long way around
sans let him hear it Westbrook ejected
from this game
you